Let's go ahead and
create our first application in Flask.
Create a file name project.py
in the same directory as
the database_setup.py file.
A minimal flask application
looks something like this.
Let's take a look at this code
together and see what's going on.
First, I imported this Flask
class from the flask library.
Next, I create an instance of this
class with the name of the running
application as the argument.
Any time we run an application in
Python, a special variable called name
gets defined for the application and
all of the imports it uses.
The application run by the Python
interpreter gets a name variable set
to __main__.
Whereas all the other important Python
files get a __name__ variable fit to
the actual name of the Python file.
Next, I have this thing that looks like
a function, but stats with an at symbol.
This is called a decorator in Python.
This decorator essentially wraps our
function inside the app.route function.
That flask is already created.
So if either of these routes
get sent from the browser,
the function that we
define here gets executed.
If this is difficult to follow,
it's okay.
I'll provide a link in the Instructor
Notes if you're interested in
learning more about decorator functions.
Just know that this @
app.route piece of code,
we'll call the function that follows it.
Whenever the website receives your
request with a URL that
matches its argument.
So in this case,
if we visit the root of the site, or
the back slash hello page, this hello
world function will be invoked.
Inside my hello world function,
I return the message I want to
display to the user's browser.
Jumping to the last line of our code,
I use the run function to run
the local server with our application.
The if statement here makes
sure the server only runs if
the script is executed directly
from the python interpreter, and
not used as an imported module.
So basically, this line of code says,
if you're executing me with
a Python interpreter, then do this.
But, if you're importing me into
another Python file, don't do this.
But you still have access
to the rest of the code.
By default, the server is only
accessible from the host machine and
not from any other computer.
This is a default.
Because in debugging mode,
a user of the application can execute
arbitrary Python code on your computer.
Since we are using a vagrant environment
for this course we must make our server
publicly available by changing the call
of the run method to look like this.
This tells the web server on my
vagrant machine to listen on
all public IP addresses.
Restarting our server each time we make
a modification to our code can get
pretty annoying, but
Flask can take care of this for us.
If you enable debug support,
the server will reload itself each
time it notices a code change.
It will also provide you a helpful
debugger in the browser if
things go wrong.
I'll save this code as project.py,
in the same directory as
my restaurant db file, and
execute it with the python interpreter.
Visiting local host port 5000 or
local host 5000 slash hello,
I see the output of my code.
To stop the server, I hit Ctrl+C.
So we see that with much
fewer lines of code,
I executed a similar version of
our hello world from lesson two.
Notice that with Flask, we don't have
to write out response codes anymore.
You will soon see that this is just one
of the several features frameworks takes
care of automatically for the developer.